Escape rooms are popping up everywhere if you haven't been to one yet. I highly recommend it
I've been to four personally and I absolutely love them if you've got the kind of mechanical mind the likes
Solving mechanisms solving challenges and deciphering codes escape room is probably for you, which brings me onto this project today
Which is inspired by Lowe's home improvement, Lowe's sponsored this collaboration and spent three months building an amazing escape room that has an incredible twist
rather than just solving clues and unlocking locks you actually have to put your DIY skills to the test and
Build your way out
I've never seen anything like it before and they turn it into a video that you can go see right now by clicking the link
at the top of the description and on the theme of
Mystery DIY escape rooms and puzzle boxes we have created this paint stick puzzle box
For about three dollars. This is one that I want you to try at home
It's so much fun and even though this thing looks really simple. There's much more to it than meets the eye
I'm going to give you a couple seconds just to look at this box
You can see all the different aspects of it, and you get a feel for it
Okay, if you shake that you can hear there's something inside of it
No obvious way in you may have noticed. There is something here, right?
If we try moving latches everything seems pretty solid for the most part there's a screw on the back there
But no obvious way to open it
Okay, so what do you guys want to try first? I'm gonna give you about five seconds to decide
what's the first thing you want to try leave your comments down below
And my guess is you're gonna go for this thing right here first because it stands out
There's nothing else on the box that looks like it. So let's give that a little wiggle
If you tug that look at that we found a little makeshift screwdriver there
So have you seen anything on the box that might need a screwdriver?
Okay, you're probably telling me that the screw on the back is the screw on the back something that can be unscrewed well. Let's see
Yeah, looks like it can
I'm gonna start unscrewing that at this point we can get into our fingers and just give it a little
Backwards motion look at that little drawer popped out
That drawer actually comes out. It's got a key in it. Now that key is just for props
We don't need it for this puzzle box, but just to demonstrate that there is something you could put in there
But there's a message at the bottom. It says to flip it over. So let's flip that over what we find is a design
And it looks like a domino or a dice. It's got five holes. What could that mean?
Is there anything on the box anywhere? Oh if we look inside there we can see almost a little target sign a little circle
And there's a hole there as well, that's interesting
So you can see that okay, so as that slides out that dowel goes into that hole right very cool
All right, so what is the five main? Let's focus on that
Oh did you notice this right here
All these look like they have finishing nail holes this one has five so what could that mean?
We take that and give it a little wiggle
Okay, there's a secret compartment there with a dowel. It's also got a little circle in the back here
Have you seen that circle anywhere else?
We've seen that on the inside right, so what could that mean well if we touch that circle and give it a little push
We get access to the large compartment what you can see has some tools in it. We have a wrench. We have an allen wrench
Again, those are just props showing that you can put other tools in there. You can put candy, plus there are a couple of pictures
What are these?
Okay there you have the guys the first reveal. This is a selfie I took at the loads DIY escape room remember
There's a link at the top of the description you can go watch the video we made
Going through that
And here's a picture of the team
I went through with you can see Bob from the I like to make stuff YouTube channel and
This puzzle box wasn't used in the escape room
But you could use it in one of your own
And of course to pack this thing back up
It's as easy as just pushing the pieces back together. Did you notice that on the front there?
There's pieces of that panel that prevents that from sliding too far back
Which is really cool
When we put in the second mystery compartment the dowel locks that one into place that it can't slide around
This little piece down here
Acts as a secondary lock to prevent you from getting into that large compartment too early and once that's in place it blends right in
Then we can take our screwdriver and screw the screw back into place
The cool thing about this is as it tightens down it actually pulls the panel in so
Even people who are trying to wiggle the sides aren't necessarily gonna find it right away because it's locked down pretty tight
And then the screwdriver itself pops right into the side and your box is now
Self-contained and ready for your next victim
Now like I said guys these boxes can be used just to hide
random stuff in your room, or you could actually use them as part of your own mystery escape room
the
Imagination is the limitation guys I want you to have fun with this
I want you to think outside the box as it were to create something inside the box
This box is a ton of fun
It's not too difficult to make I'm going to show you in the next video how to build this thing step by step what measurements to use
What materials to use and what order to follow to end up with something that looks exactly like what we have here
Took me about three weeks to prototype this and the escape room with Lowe's they literally spent three months building it
And they only let one group of people go through at one time all that
For the video that you see in the link in the description so go check it out is a fun experience
I think you're gonna enjoy it as much as we did. Thanks for joining us project guys
We'll be looking for you in the next one. Talk to you then.
[music playing]
Hey guys before you go, click right here to go see Bob
And I take on the Lowe's Black Friday
DIY escape room it was an amazing experience we had no idea what to expect once we got locked inside
So did we make it out in time you can go see for yourself by clicking right here
[music fades and stops]